all right kim it is so good to see you
again we were just saying
i feel like we're old friends now we had
a nice sit-down chat and here we are
again virtually but it is so nice to
catch up with you again i know it's so
nice to see you i love the interview we
did
a while back so it's so cool that we're
getting to
you know continue the narrative
this is gonna oh yeah we're gonna
continue this for many many years to
come first and foremost i mean we have
to talk about you landing this huge
record deal with republic records and
universal music group congratulations on
that it is so well deserved but i have
to ask who in your life had the best
reaction to that
oh well first of all i'm so excited
about that um i have an amazing team at
republic i wendy goldstein is kind of my
champion there and pushed this uh
thing through so i love you wendy shout
out um and uh yeah i just uh i love
working with them it's just such a
well-oiled machine and the support
system is just so great uh that it's
yeah it's incredible i feel i feel very
proud to be a part of that label um
but who had the best reaction to it
um
i mean probably just like my mom because
my mom was just like oh cool
let me google republic records what that
is you know
but you know my my mom will you know she
tries and my family they try to keep up
with what i do but you know they just
they don't really know what republic
records is or but and you know what any
big record company is they just love
music and artists and they're artistic
but i think it was just very cute how
like unimpressed my entire family in
germany was because i was like oh hang
on i'm signed and they're like oh let me
google that
cool
that's like the typical parent thing to
do but what was what was your own
reaction when you found out because you
were independent for a long time you
killed it as an independent artist but
like this is major having them behind
you yeah well i mean it was it was kind
of a long process because i'm i'm
protective of my creative freedom so i
wanted to maintain that so it was kind
of a thing that has been going on for
like six months or something that was
like a
period of like
yes no yes no figuring it out but they
were definitely the first label who were
like yeah whatever you need to feel
protected we will give to you and i feel
very grateful for that because it just
it puts me
so much at ease that i you know get the
way i got here is by dropping music
unconventionally and dropping it once a
week and dropping mixtapes and singles
and eps and just you know being able to
move quick so yeah i'm maintaining that
but i have an amazing family of people
who help me make my visions come to life
better you know so it's incredible and i
feel so grateful
yeah i'm so excited to see where the
future takes you listen there are some
like huge artists on that roster like
ariana grande taylor swift post malone
drake just to name a few um have you
kind of started to plant the seeds that
you would love to collaborate with any
of those type of people
of course of course i mean nikki i am a
huge bard any anybody who follows me on
twitter knows that i'm a huge huge barb
so nikki has always been a dream of mine
and i'm like is nikki recording anything
is there anything nicki means
nikki i'll do anything
so definitely with nikki i'm like
oh what is it what does it take tell her
about me please
i have a feeling i have a feeling nikki
already knows about you and that collab
would be fire
god i mean of course what else would it
be it would be iconic
because she's on it i'm just side
character yeah no but i
i
yeah that's that's like my dream of
course of course i'm like
hey wendy
what's nicky up to
you gotta put it out what's she looking
for
let me know
tell me
i love it you have so many fans of your
music and just you as a person paris
hilton listen you've been friends for
years and paris is somebody that like i
grew up with
and i just feel like her and i would be
like bff hanging out um what does it
mean to you to have her friendship and
her support behind the scenes in this
industry she's kind of like my like god
sister like she's just uh
in the beginning when i don't want it at
all my first single came out i just sent
her the song and i had like no budget
and no dressing rooms and nothing
and she was like i love this song i'm
gonna be in it and uh you know i had no
followers and nothing out there so that
was incredible and like i couldn't
believe it i'm forever so grateful for
her because she
basically introduced her platform to to
me and uh supported me and uh
i lo i was a big fan of too uh in back
in germany when i was you know living in
the middle of nowhere of hers and i had
posters on the wall i showed her
pictures of like posters on on my wall
and like
uh so it was just you know to have her
it was a dream to have her drop me off
in a pink mini at the vma for my first
performance for the first
transgender person to perform at the
vmas and
uh
and uh she's always been such an
incredible light and support
uh for the lgbtq community too you know
she's an lgbtq icon um we're icon
parents i know what everyone is
[Laughter]
um
any icon is also an
icon that's just the way it is period
very meaningful and just so
you know just full circle moment i was i
was very touched that she wanted to do
it
um you hit on something there the mtv
vmas being the first transgender person
to perform like
that is listen i wish it happened sooner
but it is happening now and that's
what's important these conversations are
happening and we're highlighting queer
artists but for you to be the first
person that's history what does that
mean for you
well i you know i just hope to open
doors
for more people for more transgender
artists
anything you know my i think my mission
in life is uh
you know to not be pointed out as
transgender and to be talked about as a
great artist a great songwriter and you
know i i see no one being like and
here's a
cisgender male straight artist
drake you know like no one says that so
for me it's like you know yes it's great
i i don't care about being the first
anything uh you know a lot of people a
lot of trans people are trans since they
can remember
so how do you measure who was first you
know also there were there were uh like
uh
there's a mandolier uh from the 70s who
had huge hits uh in europe big disco
superstar nobody knew she was trans and
then after she had big hits she came she
came out and it almost ruined her entire
career you know there's a there's a rich
history of uh
transgender artists so um i'm just i'm
just happy that i i get to do that and
that the time now allows me to make my
own platform so i don't need to have
powerful people in the industry approve
of my existence and i can just
go and do it because
i think i said this in the last
interview but a lot of people are like
you're just like a niche artist for you
know lgbt kids and uh
yeah and music is the one thing that
transcends gender and transcends
anything race
anything so uh you know it's about
emotions and it's not about
who i am or what gender i am really but
it makes me happy that i i was a part of
doing that and i hope there's many many
more people performing at the pmas who
are
i hope so too okay listen we have to
talk future starts now because this is
such a bop i am obsessed with that like
the first listen sometimes it takes me
like you know a couple a couple listens
to get into something
right from the gate i was like
holy
bleep i am obsessed um if the music
feels really hopeful and that's
something that i noticed i feel there's
an urgency of hope to this song would
you say that kind of carries through
without our throughout the rest of the
album yeah for sure thank you first
thank you i'm so glad you like it
honestly um i
my big priority during writing this
album was
fun pop music european dance music
that's what i would listen to to shut my
brain off not think about the pandemic
and uh you know just just feel alive and
feel like i'm able to
live even though i can't go outside you
know so i was just throwing around in my
room to some dab punk [ __ ] and i was
like
uh and i was like okay
um
i gotta focus on creating because it's
the one thing that i do that actually
helps me be happy you know so um i feel
like change is a good thing and i think
the world's very different now i think
everyone's kind of reflected on their
life and been like okay
actually spending this time with like my
family or my friends like those are the
important things in life you know your
friends the good the good moments the
family the supportive people those those
are things we need to prioritize or i
need to prioritize you know uh and i'm
i'm so busy that sometimes i forget so
uh
yeah so it's just about kind of beating
that depression of is the world ever
going to be okay again it's about uh
you know your future starts
now now
right now uh no but like your future
starts when you
just you know just believe that belief
that right now is all that matters and
that creates your future and it's hard
to do that in this day and age or any
day and age
because i'm stressing about the future
everyone's stressing about the future so
uh yeah it's a song to make it less
stressful
well you did you achieved that no listen
you achieved that because when i listen
to it i like i said i feel this sense of
um almost relief in a way like i'm like
okay this is this is where we are and
it's total garbage
but the future
you know there's big things ahead and
you dropped the video today kim and it
is
so damn good like this is like an epic
music video of course as a queer person
um i know like the documentary paris is
burning yeah this is this is paris is
drowning really in this video what was
the idea behind the video um the the
main idea behind the video is
kind of
accepting the end of the world and the
change of the world and
getting through it and dancing through
it and singing through it uh and
adapting to change into the future i
think that's
that's the main storyline of course the
sinking eiffel tower has been something
on my mind that i saw this entire album
because i listened to a lot of uh french
house french disco
uh things that i grew up on and uh that
really inspired me to go that route and
i think
making a europe you know euro sound
album the first thing when i think of
europe that i think about is eiffel
tower that's the first like shape i see
so
uh yeah and i just always wanted to
climb the eiffel tower while it's
sinking
i was like when i signed to republic i
was like i have to climb the eiffel
tower and it needs to sink that's my
number one condition and you guys need
to help me make that a reality can we
make that happen like yes absolutely yes
ma'am
so uh i'm so happy it's out because i
couldn't get it out of my brain like i
was like i need to do this i kept seeing
it and uh
i'm so glad that it's out because it was
a nightmare with the vfx and cgi
tell you
those things are not easy to shoot
that's for sure i got to wrap it up
really quickly but i want to hit you met
olivia rodrigo recently yes um what was
that meeting like she is incredible as
well and would you ever collab with her
of course i think she's like an
incredible songwriter i think her songs
are undeniably catchy uh every time good
for you comes on i can't help but sing
along it's she's amazing
you